- People normally, which I mean,
you do look like a fashionista.
So people usually associate with New York.
But you're now in London, right?
- I am in London.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I married an English
man, and I just stayed.
- [Kelly] Do you love it?
I love London.
- I love it so much.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
I find it, the architecture's beautiful.
The culture is, you know, it's so,
there's incredible history,
- [Kelly] History stuff, yeah.
- There's incredible art.
There's, the challenge I find, is snacks.
- Ah!
(audience laughing)
This is what I find challenging on tour.
- Yes, exactly!
- Yes.
Yeah.
- Nothing in New York.
- It's just different.
- It's different.
- Yeah.
- Firstly, the range
of snacks is different.
- Yeah.
- If you're a very snack focused person.
- It's hard.
- And secondly, everything
closes at like nine o'clock.
I'm from New York where
- [Kelly] 24 7.
- 24 7.
This is an example, like I was depressed
at four in the morning in New
York a couple of years ago,
got on Postmates, and I
was able to order a burger
on two patties of ramen.
(laughing)
At four in the morning, like.
- It's a beautiful city.
I don't care about the.
- [Kelly] The opportunity.
- I don't care about, you
know, the like big buildings.
I don't care about the,
you know, Central Park.
I care about the Ramen Burger.
- It's the Ramen Burger.
(Kelly laughing)
(audience cheering)